what's going on guys Oscar nominations
they came out a couple weeks ago and
people are saying they got it wrong
they're not diverse enough and the
Academy is just too old and out of touch
we decided we weren't just going to sit
back and complain about it we were going
to complain about it and make our own
Oscar nominations that's why we
assembled a core panel of screen junkies
we came up with nominees in six major
categories which we're going to show you
right now along with a peek at our
deliberations I'll tell you it was more
intense in there than a manitowoc jury
room so without further ado please enjoy
screen junkies first annual Oscar
nominations first up Best Supporting
Actor this category may have well been
the toughest to decide we debated we
stared each other dead in the eye what
took several minutes seemed like it took
more minutes than that even take a look
at the process okay supporting actor
Stallone is it consensus choice I fix
full of I think Stallone alone every
little pixel of all right yeah slice it
I thought it wouldn't have any names
that are not on yeah I had to do
something from Star Wars so I put the
guy that yelled traitor traitor here
traitor traitor nick has the rock as
Best Actor Best Supporting Actor Best
Actress and Best Supporting Actress and
Best Director
after Furious 7 he plucks out the
goddamn cast Jacob Trembley from the
room well now I put him as Best Actor Oh
interesting because I thought that is a
role they would disagree with that
choice I disagree hey doesn't the
Academy Awards have enough isms like do
we need to add to it with ageism we went
to hell and back in that room but we
finally came up with five nominees the
screen junkies oscar nominees for Best
Supporting Actor are Benicio del Toro
for Sicario samuel l.jackson the hateful
eight Jason Mitchell Straight Outta
Compton Mark Ruffalo spotlight
and Sylvester Stallone Creed that's
right only Ruffalo and Stallone survived
the cut from the actual Oscar
nominations we meant business next
category Best Supporting Actress and let
me tell you this one may have been the
most difficult to decide so to
paraphrase The Wizard of Oz
let's take a peek behind the curtain at
the men deciding their fake Oscar
nominations today that we could agree on
outright Jennifer Jason Leigh in a plate
Charles yeah Alex Irma candor for
Supporting Actress I put up one of the
carols I don't really care which one I'm
sure they were both great
that's a Thompson I'm in from ok with
that yeah that's a Thompson for creed
yes I could do that not Felicia Michelle
I want both my tests over Felicia all
right
I believe Kate Winslet so I'm going for
Kate okay what
Oh for Kate Winslet no I'm no Winslet
why do those choices guys it works out
Kate Winslet and andis pissed let's move
on I'd rather give it to the killer
grandma with the seeds in magic yeah
whoo Best Supporting Actress the
nominees are melissa Jaffer the old
keeper of the seeds from Mad Max fury
road yeah I'm a little perplexed about
that one too Jennifer Jason Leigh the
hateful eight Daisy Ridley Star Wars The
Force awakens Tessa Thompson Creed and
Alicia vikander ex machina for the
record Jennifer Jason Leigh and Alicia
vikander the only two holdovers from the
actual Oscar nominations but Alicia
vikander for a different movie she was
nominated for the Danish girl you see
how that works
next up Best Actor this one might have
been the hardest to decide everyone's
saying it's Leo's to lose but did he
make the screen junkies cut take a look
so Tremblay I think we all agree
definitely locked in an actor Oh read me
read me yes already a design and Matt
Damon there's a cardinal rule here that
we're breaking Redmayne show does ding
dong don't you get an automatic Nam you
show your
I would just argue for Damon because he
spent so much time on screen by himself
and it was engaging
I enjoyed that movie from start to
finish by himself just talking just
talking in a camera like reporting we
need to eliminate one of these Edgerton
Michael Jordan did you Selva yeah but
Michael B Jordan poor is not the best
part that wasn't the best part I agree
it the best public right for sure oh
yeah we're for director if we can get
rid of Michael B Jordan Howell okay Leo
made the cut he was like our first
choice but who's nominated along with
him the nominees for screen junkies
choices for Best Actor are Leonardo
DiCaprio the revenant Joel Edgerton the
gift Idris Elba beasts of no nation
Jacob Tremblay room and Taika Waititi
what we do in the shadows I'm going to
say it again because it's fun to say
take a white tee tee you might be saying
whoa that's kind of a weird list and you
got that right but here's the thing
we're not 70 year old white men in our
ivory towers deciding this we are
younger white men in our writers room
deciding this next up the category that
might have been the very hardest to
decide Best Actress
now Best Actress is a pretty strong
category in the Oscars this year but did
we even agree with a single choice of
theirs
let's take a look alright but Emily
Blunt we agree on Rytas yeah what and
remarked real arson yeah I gotta go uh
Cerys sources saoirse ronan with hell on
that one she's fantastic
I'll take your word for it you know I
look at Oscar Poe Dameron Oscar Isaac
Gillis
woo-wee so brie Larson and Saoirse Ronan
stay on the ballot but does anyone else
let's find out the nominees for Best
Actress are Emily Blunt Sicario brie
Larson
Kitana Kiki Rodriguez tangerine Saoirse
Ronan Brooklyn and Charlize Theron's Mad
Max fury road that's right furiosa makes
the cut and maybe you're saying what an
action star gets nominated hey FYI
Sigourney Weaver got nominated for
aliens so put that in your pipe and
smoke it
now it's time to honor the helmsman the
archers the visionaries aka the director
and you know what deciding this category
may have been our most difficult task of
the day take a peek
alright can we pick Kugler and get the
[ __ ] out of here Abramson for the room
do you get hard it is to direct kid
actors like that and keep a movie
exciting in a goddamn room I would back
you up on Abramson as director I would
contend that spotlight is tighter
storytelling room you give me at room
yeah yeah yes we all agree on Kugler we
all agree George Miller George Miller
uh what about fury road there is no guy
don't you
fury road stick a lock trailer not to
talk about cooler I would debate oh you
again I would debate to blur yes I would
take away cooler and put up that scary
gray McCain bull oh jeez
so would I I I could maybe do that the
nominees for Best Director are Lenny
Abramson room Ryan Coogler Creed
Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu
the revenant George Miller Mad Max fury
road and Adam McKay the big short that's
right we have four holdovers from the
actual Oscar nominations but Ryan
Coogler kicks Tom McCarthy out of his
spotlight and now the main event the
entree of our cinematic fee
Best Picture we voted wery voted we
yelled we screamed you know what stick
look by the way we're not doing this
eight nominee garbage just arrived yeah
like it changed it should be like that
yeah is there anything that's for sure
like for Furio for example that's movie
the year 1 2 3 Direction cool action not
realizing here okay what about revenant
no it's on my list not it's not the same
wasn't my favorite I feel like Sicario
was a little short-sighted in scope I
like I wanted more I felt like this yeah
let's do one more
um more of a movie I nominate room I I
it depends that's like five or six it's
it's wow this is the hardest Oh after
all that in spite of the fact that Nick
Mundy had only seen two movies this year
we came up with five not eight or ten
whatever the Academy does five
nominees for Best Picture and the
nominees are ex machina inside-out Mad
Max fury road room and Sicario Wow Room
and Mad Max the only holdovers are you
pissed the revenant isn't on the list I
am I like legitimately am there you have
it the first annual screen junkies Oscar
nominations what you think of our list
are you a crazy person that thinks
entourage should be on there let us know
in the comments section below tell us
your picks for all six categories and
another way to have your say is to head
over to screen junkies com where you can
vote on some of the winners and the
categories we just listed check the link
in the description below I want to thank
you for watching
I'm how Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye the best new character award the
nominees raid from the force awakens
bing-bong from inside out eggsy from the
Kingsman the Secret Service and your
winner the doof warrior from Mad Max
fury road you know what forget furiosa
prequel I want more doof warrior show me
the whole doof band with the doof
drummer and the duke keyboardist and the
duke lead singer